[MUSIC]
It's summer 2018, I'm sitting at my
desk and one of my clients walks in.
He drops his bag on the floor and
turns to the others in the office,
asking what they think
of the latest headline
about Brett Kavanaugh's
nomination to the Supreme Court.
As the ten men around me casually debate
whether he had actually assaulted Dr.
Blasey Ford, I feel my chest tighten.
I see them speaking, but their voices
drop off and I can't hear anything.
I stumble to the bathroom
in search of privacy.
As the memories begin to flood my brain,
I bury my face in my palms.
I can't stop them.
Suddenly, someone walks
into the bathroom and
the noise is enough to jolt
me back into the present.
I take a deep shaky breath, and walk
back to my desk as if nothing happened.
These episodes continued and
became unbearable.
I knew I needed help, and
finally made an appointment with
a therapist who would change my life.
She helped me see that these were
PTSD-like flashbacks common among trauma
survivors.
I had thought these were
work-related anxiety attacks.
I had no idea and I hadn't even realized
that my client's comments where triggering
flashbacks to my own experience
with sexual assault.
An experience I'd suppressed for
years, now rearing its head.
It was clear I would need to make time for
consistent regular therapy to address
these flashbacks and
their underlying cause.
Unfortunately, the only time
available in my therapist's
practice was Tuesday mornings at 9:30 AM,
right in the middle of the weekly update
to our clients that I usually lead.
I dreaded bringing this up with my boss.
I didn't want him to think I was weak
by disclosing that I was dealing with
a mental health issue.
I decided to frame it vaguely
around a medical issue.
Surely he'd understand that.
I approached him one day
on our way out of work,
stumbling over my words as I tried to
blurt them out as quickly as possible.
I need to see a doctor weekly for
treatment, and
the only time available
is Tuesdays at 9:30 AM.
I know that conflicts with our
weekly client meetings, but
this is a priority for me and
I'm hoping you can help me.
He looks concerned.
Is this a serious medical issue?
Would extended medical
leave be a better option?
No, now he actually thought I
had a serious medical condition.
I decided to backtrack and
tell him the truth.
No, no, it's nothing serious.
Well, it is serious.
I'm going through a tough time and
I need to see a therapist weekly.
He nodded slowly, are there any other days
of the week you could see your therapist?
Could you see them before or
after working hours?
I shook my head, no,
this is the only time available.
Maybe you could go every other week.
No, I need to see this person every week,
that's non-negotiable.
He looked at me for a beat and
I saw something shift in his face.
You know what, do what you have to do,
we'll make it work.
As I reflect back on this experience, it
makes me sad to realize that the only way
I thought my mental health would be taken
seriously was to claim a physical illness.
If in 2018 I'd torn my ACL and
needed physical therapy,
I would have had no
problem going to my boss.
So why did it feel so much harder
to share my mental health needs?
One year later, I myself was
leading a team on a high profile,
high stress project with
one of our largest clients.
And I could tell something was wrong.
One of the associates on my team, we'll
call her Rachel, usually very focused and
high-performing, seemed distracted.
I checked in with her one-on-one and
she shared that she was
struggling with depression, but
unable to consistently see her therapist
because of our travel schedules.
As consultants, we typically traveled
to be on site, at our clients,
Monday to Thursday,
spending three nights on the road.
My heart ached for
Rachel when she told me this.
I thought back to my moment
of crisis here earlier and
I wanted to help her get
the support she needed.
But again,
I was nervous to bring it up with my boss.
I was concerned he might think that I and
the team couldn't handle the pressures of
the job, which we'd signed up for
knowing involved travel.
And I was up for a promotion, and
I was worried my manager might doubt my
leadership abilities if I didn't tell
Rachel, no, we have to be there.
This is what the client wants.
But I wasn't willing to tell her no,
I wanted to help her get
the support she needed.
I knew firsthand the impact
that an hour a week with my
therapist had made on my mental health,
and I wanted the same for her.
I set up time with my boss and
I told him the team wanted to reduce
our number of days on the road.
He initially pushed back saying, the
clients aren't paying us to sit at home.
But eventually, after I emphasized
the physical and mental toll this
was taking on the team, he agreed to try
out a three day a week travel schedule.
The team stuck with it, and Rachel was
able to see her therapist every Thursday.
Now, I don't claim to be the model
of effective management, after all,
this was before my MBA.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
the impact that my personal experience had
had on me allowed me to empathize with
Rachel and
help her get the support she needs.
I recognize not every work
environment will be this flexible.
But in the white collar, salaried work
environments many of us will go into after
we graduate, why is it so hard to imagine
a work environment where employees can
prioritize their mental health, even if
it's just an hour a week for therapy?
My view is that making space for
mental health at work is hard because the
stigma around mental health still exists.
80% of employees reported
stigma in the workplace about
mental health in a recent
survey from April 2021.
Which is astounding when you
realize that in reality,
20% of American adults
struggle with mental illness.
Let that sink in.
One in five American adults you walk by on
the street, see in the grocery store, and
who are even sitting in this room,
are struggling with their
mental health on a daily basis.
And to make matters worse, less than half
of those people get the treatment or
support they need.
To put it into context, one in five
Americans has been diagnosed with
COVID-19 to date,
the same prevalence as mental illness.
Mental health is the pandemic
we're not talking about.
Our deprioritization of mental
health isn't a new challenge.
However, we have structurally valued
mental health to a lesser degree
than physical health.
Mental health benefits are less likely to
be covered by health insurance plans, and
are reimbursed at lower
rates when they are.
The number of federally funded
residency positions in psychiatry has
remained flat since the 1990s,
even as the population has grown and
demand for
mental health services has soared.
These are just a few of the systemic
barriers preventing access to affordable
mental health services.
Today, I want to focus on what we
all can do in our everyday lives to
break down the stigma
around mental health, and
help people take that first
step towards seeking care.
I believe we can accomplish this by
shifting our perspective around mental
health to be equally as important
as our physical health.
Prevention, trauma, and
recovery exist in both realms.
Why should we think differently of either?
We can start by normalizing mental health
at home, in our private lives, and
in conversations with friends and family,
and also in our public lives, at work.
It's at work where I see
the greatest potential for
a shift in stigma around mental health.
Now, much has been written about what
corporations can do at an organizational
level to support employee mental health.
I want to focus on what we all can do
in our everyday interactions at work to
support those struggling
with mental health.
We can start by checking
in on our people and
asking those on our teams what
they need to be at their best.
Hear your employees and
respect their needs,
without judging whether their needs
are worth investing time into therapy.
Ask yourself if an employee or colleague
of yours needed physical therapy,
would you respond differently?
And don't underestimate your role
in creating a supportive work
environment through small
changes to your daily schedule.
I challenge you to ask these questions
of yourselves to better support those
struggling with mental health at work.
Can you be the one to role model
what it looks like to make space for
mental health at work?
It might make a world of a difference to
someone on your team, as it did for me.
I still see a psychologist every week,
four years later, and
I am still working through the effects
of the trauma I experienced.
But the impact of managers who
respected the boundaries I set at work
cannot be overstated.
They took my mental health seriously and
respected my needs when I made them known.
My team was fine without me at
that weekly client meeting.
All I needed was a compassionate manager
who was willing to step in for me.
I challenge you to be that compassionate
manager for those on your teams and
in your workplace.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]